Hey everyone.
This video was done in collaboration with our good friends over at the tape,
stick around until the end of the video,
to hear more about their deep dive into princess, Carolyn
What's up wisecrack, Jared. Again, in case you missed it.
Two of our favorite shows in recent memory wrap this year,
the good place and BoJack horseman. Now on paper,
these shows might seem very different.
One's a feel good show about a ragtag team of dead people trying to save
everyone from member flattening. Hell.
Maybe if you score negative points on earth, I'm sorry. You blew it.
Enjoy having your penis flattened.
While the other one is about, well, this prick, maybe.
Some of the troops are heroes, but not automatically.
I'm sure a lot of the troops are jerks.
But what if I told you that if you dig a little deeper,
these shows actually approach the same philosophical topic from opposite
perspectives. Oh dear. As it turns out,
both the good place and BoJack are preoccupied, not just with death,
but with how the big slumber gives meaning to our lives.
So in the words of everyone's favorite Florida, man,
let's hook them all top cocktail the thing and see what happens.
Logan was wisecrack condition on two ways to die,
the good place and BoJack horseman.
And as always spoilers ahead now for the uninitiated,
the good place has a lot of twists and turns over its four seasons.
The show started as a story about humans mistakenly ending up in heaven only to
surprise us with the revelation that their good place was. In fact,
an intricate plot to torture them.
But after getting a surprisingly good looking demon on their side, hello,
silver Fox, the show follows the gang.
As they try to change the rules that govern the afterlife.
That's because the current system is seriously broken.
And this is the problem with the current system live anything less than the most
exemplary life. And you are brutally tortured forever with no recourse.
The cruelty of the punishment does not match the cruelty of the life.
That one has lived.
To fix the problem. The judge kind of like a pseudo God with a daddy complex.
Wow.
Last time I checked, I didn't have a dad.
That's why I'm attracted to all the father figures on the TV shows. I watched.
Wants to erase humanity and start from scratch.
But the gang manages to convince her and the folks down in the bad place to
adopt a new system. You die,
go to the afterlife and then go through a series of tests.
Before you move on to heaven.
Again,
you were given a sort of evaluation and the architects explain what you did
badly, what you did well, and then you get rebooted and do it again.
And again and again until you ACE, it.
All's well, that ends well, right? Not so much. Well,
the gang may have stopped all humanity from going to hell.
That doesn't mean that heaven is all that great.
In the words of Hypatia of Alexandria.
Paper, this is paradise. All your desires and needs are met,
but it's infinite. And when perfection goes on forever,
you become this glassy-eyed mushy person.
Living forever is kind of its own hell. So Eleanor has a solution.
The way to restore meaning to the people in the good place is to let.
Them leave.
In other words, for your afterlife to have meaning you too must die,
or in this case, cease to exist. The show wraps up with our heroes,
all doing what they need to feel at peace before shuffling off this immortal
coil. Now,
if you think it's strange that a show about the afterlife ends with everyone
essentially dying, that's probably because you're not familiar with this guy.
Mortality offers meaning to our lives and morality helps navigate that
meaning.
Wait,
what I think it says is that mortality offers meaning to the events of our life.
Nice that dude, right there is Todd may.
Who's not only a professor of philosophy,
but also a philosophical advisor to the show with Pamela Harami it's May's book
death that actually provides the philosophical framework for the series ending
in it may make the bold claim.
That the fact that we die is the most important fact about us. For me,
death provides a unique structure to our lives with death,
subsuming all other facts about our lives without death.
He argues we would all lose a sense of meaning and maybe even virtue to prove
the point may ask us to consider Jorge Luis bore has this short story via
mortal,
which follows a man named Joseph [inaudible] in search of a river that grants
and mortality.
But when cartel is finally drinks from the river and discovers the society of
immortals, he's shocked to find that they're just apathetic,
husks of former humans. They barely talk show,
strikingly little interest in others and wander about in the literal ruins of
their own civilization. If this sounds familiar to you,
maybe that's because it reminds you of this delightful character in the good
place. Paul T-ball what's your favorite positive.
Yeah, I mean, it's perfect. We're all having orgasms literally all the time.
I died a Virgin. So that's real crazy.
Because there's nothing that the residents of the good place haven't done or
will not eventually do during that eternity.
Nothing provides them meaning or joy.
Even the literal constant cosmic orgasmic bliss or go-karting with monkeys.
Donkeys are the ideal go-kart opponents.
They're funny enough to give the finger, but not smart enough to win.
Perhaps worse.
This unending life seems to also strip people of their identities.
Hypatia of Alexandria, for example,
becomes the exact opposite of an erudite ancient philosopher.
She swaps her Toga for an NFL Jersey,
goes by the name Patty and has totally forgotten the name of her former
profession.
Where are you? What's it called a, um, a think book, man.
Um.
But it's not just our passions that eternity would numb may sites,
fellow philosopher,
Martha Neusbaum and speculating that eternity could even chip away at our moral
concerns going so far as to speculate that even justice would be imperiled.
The needs of others would not urge themselves on us in the same way since their
existence would not be threatened by our neglect.
This is certainly the case in bore has his story where car topless relates,
how a man was left at the bottom of a ravine for almost a century because no one
could be bothered to get him out after all.
Why rush when you have until the end of time and while the good place didn't
quite bear this thesis out. It's interesting to note that after an eternity,
Chidi who made moral philosophy,
his whole life on earth and the afterlife was no longer interested in studying
the subject. Once he got to.
The good place. After a thousand times of reading,
the most difficult writings in the world have acquired a new passion,
garbage books.
Do you think it would have been a good symbologist here's that learner real job.
But the good place.
And Todd may both agree that eternity is a less than great everything needs an
it may, for his part, asks his readers to consider a novel,
a book concluding isn't important in and of itself.
Literally every book in existence has a final page,
but this ending itself lets you reflect on what came before and gives you a
chance to order that experience. Or we can consider your typical TV sitcom.
The fact that there's a final scene to each episode, isn't surprising,
but building to that end allows the episode to have a narrative drive and a
sense of closure for the good place.
The knowledge of finality allows the show and its characters to create meaning
the chance to walk through a door of non-existence allows Jason to feel complete
when he played the perfect game of Madden after over 400,000 tries and it allows
Chidi to feel at peace when he and Eleanor sit down for their last dinner
together as Michael paraphrases, Eleanor.
You said that every human is a little bit sad all the time because you know,
you're going to die,
but that knowledge is what gives life meaning.
But if all of this seems a bit overly well optimistic,
then maybe BoJack horseman. His perspective would speak to you more.
After all BoJack has spent six seasons deconstructing the idea that anything in
life can be neatly wrapped up, let alone in the face of death.
It's funny, isn't it?
The things that matter the truth is none of it matters.
And the truth is it all matters tremendously.
It's a wonder any of us ever get out of bed at all.
And yet we get out of bed.
And the final half of season six is no different.
While BoJack seems to have turned a new sober leaf as a drama teacher at
Wesleyan, everything goes South for him. When two Intrepid,
1930 style reporters start poking around his past.
This last story is taking its sweet time.
But once we can tie down this boat plus house fellow to Sarah Lynn on the night
of her death wield, are you broke you on the phone?
Well, it begins as a story about BoJack's involvement in Sarah Lynn's death,
quickly spirals into a PR nightmare with BoJack getting grilled for all his
horrible behavior on national TV.
When she was intoxicated, you had sex with her. And when she was sober,
you gave her the heroin that killed her.
Then in an effort to cover for yourself,
you waited to call the paramedics that might've saved her life.
One relapsed later complete with a near death experience.
And one of the best dream sequences on television and BoJack has been sentenced
to 14 months in jail.
The series ends with BoJack being released for a night to attend princess
Carolyn's wedding,
where he must accept the fact that life doesn't have any rhyme or reason he just
simply has to get by. Yeah. Well, what are you going to.
Do? Life's a. And then you die, right?
Sometimes, sometimes life's a. And then you keep living.
It's that last sentence that really encapsulates the philosophical essence of
the show. Life's a. And then you die.
Or sometimes you just keep on living. Unlike the good place.
There are no clear cut endings in BoJack horseman,
no real moments to get a greater sense of closure. Sure.
BoJack might make a big gesture of change at the end of one season,
whether it's saving Todd from an improv Colt or showing kindness to his mother
on her death bed, but he always slides.
This place was supposed to be a fresh start for me.
Rehab was supposed to be a fresh start, no matter how many starts I get,
there's always the same ending. Everything falls apart. And I end up alone.
Put endings in BoJack offer little to no meaning. So it's not too surprising.
Then that death,
the end of all ends is likewise treated as a frightening meaningless, unknown.
This all hearkens back to the early French variety of existentialism to
paraphrase the original bad boy of French philosophy.
John Paul Sartre humans are created without any specific purpose.
Unlike toilet paper,
which is obviously made to be bought and hoarded like precious gold.
We enter this world without any rhyme or reason and only define ourselves
afterwards.
But whatever one finds in their quest for meaning it's all for not as the cosmic
curtain comes to a close, some existential nihilist,
even go a step further and say, why bother searching at all?
And the words of philosopher, Donald Crosby, stretch,
fret and dilute ourselves as we may,
our lives are of no significance and it is futile to seek or to affirm meaning
where none can be found while existential nihilism is as far away as possible
from Todd May's argument, that death gives life.
Meaning it's been a constant staple for BoJack. In fact,
death punctuates almost every season with the deaths of herb.
Because as Sarah Lynn and BoJack's mother all causing BoJack to hit new
emotional lows and subsequently scrambled to make sense of his life.
I don't know how to be. Diane doesn't get better and it doesn't get easier.
Season six, where the show really drives the existentialist message home.
Particularly in the episode, the view from halfway down after BoJack relapses,
he breaks into his old home. It takes a bunch of pills, drinks,
a bunch of vodka, and then has a near death experience while drowning.
Finally made it to a little soiree. Yeah.
Having this dream where I was having dinner with all the people who were gone
and I thought I shouldn't do that.
In the dream. BoJack has dinner with all the people he knew who died.
Also Zach Braff.
The waiter water. Thank you, Zach breath.
What starts as a dinner game about the best and worst parts of the game.
Characters lives quickly devolves into a conversation about the value of these
lives.
Sarah Lynn insists that all the joy she brought her fans must mean something
while corduroy Jackson, Jackson,
you know the guy who hanged himself while jerking off and sucking on a lemon,
says it can't equal. BoJack's uncle's sacrifice.
You sing in songs on stage. It's the same thing as this guy who died liberated,
we can't compare apples to Auschwitz.
Notably,
this isn't the structured kind of philosophical conversation we would see play
out in the good place or an answer or resolution has always found at the end of
22 minutes. Instead there's no agreement, no answers here.
BoJack's father represented by secretary. It says it best.
What they did with their lives. Didn't matter.
All the time those people spent trying to do good or help people would be
something. I did none of that. And yet here I am. Same as them.
Regardless of what they did on earth or who they were, they all died.
Any attempts to create meaning or to find peace or just desperation.
Piece that someone trying to convince himself as something of what the life has,
meaning or purpose, that, that if you check the right boxes and do the dance,
then you get a little part and get to the end frame certificate that says,
congratulations. You've got peace.
Of course, BoJack is anything.
But at peace when he realizes he won't be waking up from the stream.
Not coming, Oh, this is always the part where I wake up. You all go to the show?
Zach Braff says, pardon my reach.
Even though he can clearly get my plate from another angle, then I wake up. Oh,
okay.
Instead BoJack joins the others for a literal show. One by one,
the characters perform artistic rendition of their deaths.
Sarah Lynn sings a song about how you shouldn't stop performing until you're
dead corduroy, uh, hangs himself and secretary at slash BoJack's.
Father reads a haunting poem about jumping off the bridge, thrash.
To break from gravity.
What now could slow the drop highlight,
give for toast to touch the safety packet time.
At the end of all of these performances,
the characters exit through a door of non-existence.
But this door isn't the serene wooded variety we see in the good place.
It's an abyss.
It's a stark contrast where the good place strives to tell us that death will be
peaceful and that you'll go willingly.
Will happen when we go through it. Well,
we don't really know exactly.
All we know is it will be peaceful and your journey will be over.
BoJack implies that it's terrifying and you're going whether you want to or not.
Now, while it might be tempting to chalk this all up to BoJack's traders,
being a bit more artistic in their visions of death.
These choices are actually integral to existentialism.
Most existential has argued that if meaning exists in the world,
it is an entirely human construct. According to Sartre,
when we perceive the world around us,
what we're actually doing is trying to impose order upon it.
He writes it's our presence in the world, which multiplies relations it is.
We who set up this relationship between this tree and a bit of sky.
Thanks to us. That star,
which has been dead for millennia that quarter moon and that dark river are
disclosed in the unity of a landscape. More importantly,
existentialists argue that this mental process is what allows humans to be free.
Sure. There's no grand purpose to our existence,
but that doesn't mean we can't attempt to create one for ourselves.
And the artist who distills their vision of the world onto a canvas or a stage
is perhaps the most free of all.
It explains why so many existentialists like Sartre Camou and Beauvoir were also
playwrights. And it explains why herb tells BoJack this during his dream.
Has anyone ever come back from this place?
There is no place.
It's just your brain going through what it feels like it has to go through.
All you can do right now is sit back and enjoy the show.
This was real. It's simply BoJack creating art from his life.
Trying to impose order in the end,
BoJack has to come to the sobering realization that this is it.
You on the other side, hope BoJack. No,
there is no other side. This is him.
Of course, BoJack doesn't actually die. And maybe that's the point.
Think back to May's point.
The idea that death gives structure and meaning to a life,
if a person never died, if the book never ended, if the show just went on,
then at what point would we be able to sit back and ask ourselves?
What does it all mean? Ultimately,
the good place chose the sitcom ending one where the characters all completed
their journeys and found peace.
Even if that meant their existence is coming to an end.
I just suddenly had this calm feeling like the
air inside my lungs was the same as the air, outside my body.
It was peaceful.
In BoJack. The show ends, but the journey continues even BoJack.
Doesn't really know what he's going to do or how it's going to beat.
But it's easy now in jail. I don't have to make any choices for myself.
I worry about what's going to happen.
We keep coming back to that line from the final scene. Sometimes life's a.
And then you keep living in the last scene.
BoJack confronts the reality that he'll never totally make things right with
Diane, but even so life will go on as approving, proving the point,
the last moments of the show.
Aren't uncomfortably long shot of the two sitting awkwardly next to each other
in silence. So here's the million dollar question wise,
crack and asking how death affects life.
Why did the good place end on simple answers?
And why did BoJack end with open questions? Strangely?
I think the answer lies not necessarily in the shows themselves,
but in their creators and more importantly,
their mediums after all the good places, the baby of Michael. Sure.
One of the most influential figures in American television. Sure.
Cut his teeth on the American office before creating parks and rec Brooklyn
nine, nine, and the good place. In other words, he's an honest to God,
sit-com genius, but sitcoms as a form have their own narrative demands.
Dan Harmon said it best. When he wrote that TV, isn't selling revolution,
it's selling a hygienic relatable substitution for your own filthy unmarketable
humanity.
The trick that television plays is that it swaps out any meaningful and
therefore potentially television subverting truth with the basic eternal truth.
That change is unnecessary.
Ultimately the traditional TV model is focused on placating audiences.
TV wants to make you feel good,
even safe about your lives that you'll watch more TV.
The last thing he wants to do is create an existential crisis,
but this is exactly what BoJack horseman does.
And it's precisely because the man behind the show Raphael,
Bob Wachsberg is not from Hollywood. In fact like many existentialists,
Bob Wachsberg is a playwright by training. And as a result,
BoJack oozes theatricality, the episode time's arrow, for example,
freely draws on theater inspirations like Harold Pinter and Carol Churchill by
depicting Beatrice's dementia as her mixing and mashing various moments of her
life.
Another episode free chiro is essentially a one man show a 20 minute monologue
in which BoJack delivers a eulogy about his mother Beatrice.
And it's also one of the top TV episodes of all time on IMD.
Be given Bob Wachsberger pension for theater and all its existential baggage.
It's not surprising that BoJack has shoes,
the easy answers and happy endings of networks.
TV closure is a made up thing by Steven Spielberg to sell movie tickets.
It's like true love. And the Munich Olympics doesn't exist in the real world.
The only thing to do now is just to keep living forward. In the end.
We get a very interesting dichotomy.
The good place attempts to be a show about philosophy.
Even the starting premise for people stuck in hell,
torturing each other is inspired by John Paul.
Sartre's famous play no exit yet because of the shows sitcom routes.
It's bound to answers that can easily fit the sitcom mold of clean endings.
It wants to Sue thus with the traditional sitcom logic that it's all going to be
okay. As long as we have our friends or as Chidi puts it,
We should just be excited that any show network television or otherwise is
willing to talk about content.
You reading the metaphysics of morals by Emmanuel Kant.
It's a treatise on the aesthetic preconditions of the mind's receptivity to
duty.
The other hand, BoJack horseman is the exact opposite of the good place.
It's a show set in Hollywood that because of its theater roots ends up being
about philosophy. And to be sure we never get the answer to a lot of questions.
Is there meanings?
The damage we experience are we doomed to always be the people we are now and.
Stars and celebrities? What do they know? Do they know things let's find out.
But in all seriousness,
just as the show leaves us uncertain about how BoJack's journey will go.
It leaves us uncertain about the meaning of life, death,
and any other deeper philosophical questions.
And in that there's a certain genuineness and authenticity that the good place
lacks still itching to learn about every nook and cranny of BoJack horseman
genius.
Be sure to check out the takes video on the only person who somehow stayed
friends with BoJack princess, Carolyn,
it explores the working woman trope she embodies and her unique relationship to
storytelling.
The take has a ton of cool videos exploring the tropes that are everywhere in
your favorite movies and shows.
They've got a whole bunch of videos on the good place BoJack and my absolute
favorite, the matrix click here to check them out.
Be sure to subscribe and tell them wisecrack sent ya.
Thanks for watching everybody.
Peace.